This video is made possible by Nord VPN take control of your internet experience
today.
Go to Nord vpn.com forward slash biographics and use the code biographics to get
70% off a three year plan and next month for free and take control of your
internet experience. Now,
There are a handful of writers throughout history whose men names somehow
conjures up everything they were about. If someone says Stephen King,
you think of a master of horror.
Agatha Christie makes one think about detective mysteries.
Mark Twain has a similar effect since we connect him with a smarmy witty
affectionately [inaudible] type of writing.
He's widely considered to be one of the most important humorists in American
history, responsible for creating several world famous novels.
If an author worked all of their lives and only created the adventures of Tom
Sawyer, that would be considered a successful career.
Mark Twain produced that timeless classic can many more.
Today we're going to dive deeper into the complicated, hilarious,
sometimes radical life of mystery.
Swain was actually born Samuel Clemens on November the 30th, 1835 in Florida,
Missouri as one of seven children.
He quickly watched many of his siblings to come and die.
During childhood only three Clemens children reached adult at the age of four.
Samuel moved with his family to the town of Hannibal situated on the Mississippi
river. His father,
John Marshall Clemens worked as a sometimes attorney and sometimes judge
Samuel's mother was named Jane who hailed from Kentucky during his childhood.
Samuel would often play around the port of Hannibal swimming and fishing and
creating memories that would inform his future works.
John Clemens took ill with pneumonia when Samuel was 11 and passed away,
they hadn't much to speak for financially even before he died,
but they were especially bad off afterwards. Even at his young age,
Samuel had to find work to help around the house all while still continuing his
education at school,
still money was a pressing enough need that he eventually had to quit classes
all together. After the fifth grade, interestingly enough,
some of the first jobs he had were the local newspapers.
He operated presses for one and wrote short stories for another.
By the time he reached the age of 18,
he struck out of a small Missouri town and headed for the brighter working
environs of the big city, moving from New York city to Philadelphia to St.
Louis, tell me all,
even joined a printers trade union while continuing his education on his own by
visiting the vast libraries at the cities,
in which he dwelled the water seemed to still call to him the river and docks,
where he grew up,
had a hold over him and he wanted to learn how best to traverse them.
The idea of becoming a boat pilots in trans Stemmons.
He took on an apprenticeship with a licensed steam boat pilots learn how to
navigate the mighty Mississippi and navigate.
He did reading the currents and learning how to avoid the dangers that any pilot
could encounter on such a huge body of water.
And in two years he and his license, he also encountered it. Um,
that would stick with it was a standard depth of water that was safe for a steam
boat to travel in equal to 12 feet or two fathoms known to Boltzmann as Mark
Twain. He would also soon adopt it as it's pending
War began to brew in 1861 Clemens. Now age 26,
decided to destroy a house in the American West.
He had served on the Mississippi for a few years,
even offering his brother Henry a job on a Steamboat that partnership ended in
tragedy as Henry was killed. When the boat's boiler went up in flames,
Samuel was beside himself with grief and then seeing the brother against brother
conflict of the civil war rearing its ugly hand.
He finally decided to take a new opportunity working in Nevada with another
sibling, Iran,
Iran and Clemens became the secretary of the Nevada territory in 1861,
working under governor James knife,
Samuel joined a rod and the two headed West on a two week stagecoach trip.
He decided to leave the voyage and set foot in Virginia city, Nevada,
where he tried his luck at mining.
It didn't last long and he soon took a more familiar position at the local
paper.
This is notable because it was the first time he officially used his pen name,
Mark Twain in an 1863 humor piece.
So this is what we shall refer to him as from now on Mark Twain would tuck away
all sorts of experiences and stories he gained while spending time in the West,
traveling to San Francisco and enjoying the weather and fruits that California
had to offer. During this time he produced his first published success.
The celebrated jumping frog of Calaveras County,
which was printed in a New York paper and quickly gains in the following in
1867, Twain was offered a chance to tour Europe and the Mediterranean with this
newspaper employer footing the bill. These travels inspired the work,
the innocence abroad, but also on the trip.
He befriended a fellow passenger named Charles Langdon.
When Langdon showed Mark a photograph of his sister,
Olivia Twain was taken aback by her beauty and fell in love instantly the two
who kept in contact for the next two years,
Twain trying to compel her to marry him once, but she rejected him in February,
1870 Olivia finally relented and the do were weds in New York where they would
live for a time. Now, just before we get into the rest of today's video,
would you want to take a quick moment to tell you about today's sponsor Nord
VPN. Now, if you're online, you really must be using a VPN.
And that's where Nord VPN comes in.
I know it's tempting not to bother sorta just hope for the best, but ready,
those stories you read about people having that data stolen, they do happen,
and you don't want to make it easy for anyone to do that to you.
Whether it's a nefarious actor snooping for your private information or
companies tracking your activity, but using a VPN can be about so much more.
For example,
nor VPN lets you access any of its thousands of servers in different countries,
all around the globe. So if you hit the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and get access to content
libraries that due to licensing agreements are going to be available in specific
geographic locations. I'm random to that problem.
I think in the past with mad men, it was available in America,
but not in Europe. So VPN definitely solve that problem.
No VPN is also super fast. Watching a video is a breeze.
There's no lag whatsoever. If you've ever thought VPNs were slow. Well,
no more with Nord VPN. And so you can use it on all of your devices,
very easily, Android Chrome windows, Linux,
and on six different devices with just one accounts.
Also there are no logs at all.
Unlike companies that are based in the EU or the U S nor VPN is over in Panama.
So they didn't have to keep logs at all, which is great for your privacy.
So take control of your internet experience right now,
go to Nord vpn.com forward slash biographics and do use code biographics to get
70% of the three-year plan and an extra month for free take control of your
internet experience.
Right?
73 Twain and Olivia would begin to set some roots in Hartford, Connecticut.
They had a home built.
Olivia had a separate part of the house designed for Mark to be able to write in
and smoke his cigars habit sheet to test it.
The Hartford house was where Twain would produce some of his most treasured
classics, that three daughters while they resided there as well.
Susie Clara and Jean, the next door neighbor was Hamlet, Beecher Stowe,
author of uncle Tom's cabin. When they went on summer vacation,
they visited Olivia's sister who lived in the same town in which they were
married and spent time with a wealthy family.
Twain would use these rest bites to upstate New York to write as well.
His writings were gaining him more and more of an audience by these times.
But 1876 is the adventures of Tom Sawyer was the novel that brought him
worldwide. Acclaim Twain,
leaned every experience you had from his childhood to bring a story to life of
the young titular character and his times growing up along the Mississippi
river, it was also one of the first novels created on a typewriter,
considered an absolute classic of American literature.
Tom Sawyer set him on a streak of successes.
He was making money and traveling all over the country on leisure sockets.
He also really loved writing travel books as evidenced by 1880s of tramp abroad,
which detailed Twain and his time in Germany, France and Switzerland,
the book offered a taste of his wit with the classic fish out of water device
playing well with an American out of his element in Europe,
the Prince and the pulper was released in 1881. Twain was now on a roll.
The tale dealt with two characters. You switch identities in 16th century,
England Twain use the plot to expose social injustice and show just how
differently separate classes of people were.
And always have been in 1883 Twain again,
revisited his beloved river routes in life. On the Mississippi. With this,
he actually turned a bit scholarly educating on the history of the river bus
with a bit of his riverboat pioneering expertise sprinkled in life on the
Mississippi. It was almost a prime of a Twain, however, as he would in 1884,
flesh out one of old Tom Sawyer as friends for a novel of his own,
the adventures of huckleberry Finn huckleberry Finn would take on an even more
socially conscious SLAM's than much of his previous work.
As Twain looked at the burning wasteland of the civil war and the way that
African-Americans were being treated,
turning a mirror on Americans in the process,
1889 is a Connecticut Yankee in King Arthur's court.
It was one of Twain's last big novels, and it's a man wakes up,
suddenly thrust into the time of King Arthur Twain was able to implement much of
his darker cynical signs that was creeping in.
As he approached his golden years,
there would be much more to be dark and cynical about. He would soon.
Yeah.
Swain actually used his own publishing company for the first time in the
printing of huckleberry Finn.
He was keen to maintain artistic control and make the money that his art was
bringing in.
It would make you think that Twain had a good sense of finances and how to spend
it wisely, but you would be wrong. He was terrible at investing money.
He was amazed by technology and often through vast sums of money at new
inventions that he thought would change the world.
The page typesetting machine was a glorious failure that he loved with his heart
and his wallet.
The world was evolving at such a rate and newspapers and print was blowing up so
fast that handset type machines simply couldn't contact anymore.
The page machine promised to take Prince into the new world,
but it requires such precise calibration and constant maintenance that it became
obsolete almost as soon as it was released.
And it was left behind by smarter quicker machines,
Twain poured around $300,000 of his own money,
trying to keep the page typesetter afloat,
which is over $9 million in today's money.
He continually dipped into the money.
He had earned from his books and even his wife's family inheritance to keep the
dying machine afloat. But in the end, it was all for naught.
Even as publishing companies struggled to turn a profit and things got so bad
between that,
they had to shutter their Connecticut home and set up meager accommodations in
Europe, sometime in the 1890s,
Twain struck up a friendship with a mercurial inventor, Nikola Tesla.
Tesla was resigning in New York city at the time.
And Twain often visited the metropolis,
especially after he got wind of some of the amazing inventions that Tesla was
concocting.
Tesla was a scientist Westinghouse at the time and was working on a new kind of
electric motor Twain was a frequent visitor to Tesla's lab and loved interacting
with his new gadgets and devices.
One such device Tesla was creating involved a vibrating oscillator machine,
which was basically an engine that put out high frequencies Tesla ones.
And if there could be any health benefits that could be gained from the
invention and knew that his friends,
Mark Twain sometimes suffered from digestive problems and constipation,
Dwayne got on the machine and instantly felt sensations of like Talenti until
such time that the machine rattled his bowels and off to effectively cure him
train. And Tesla continued that friendship for years,
Tesla reportedly tried out an x-ray gun and shot it. Twain's head.
Tesla was invited to Twain's daughter's wedding, Hank Morgan,
the time-traveling character in Twain's,
a Connecticut Yankee and going off his course may have been based on the
eccentric Tesla Twain had to embark on a worldwide tour of lectures to try and
get the family back into profits in 1896 Twain's 24 year old daughter.
Susie was visiting that Connecticut hometown when she was struck with
meningitis, sadly,
she died from the onus and Mark Twain never returned to the place where his
greatest love and fortunes had flowered citing the pain of her death.
There being too much to bat.
Dwayne didn't even return to the United States until 1900.
When he moved to New York city,
it was a period of deep dark depression and despair for Twain is rising,
was reflecting the darker side of humanity and focusing its bobs at the failures
of government and disappointment in humanity in general.
He even publicly insulted Winston Churchill before introducing him.
It's an event he began to be seen as a treasure of sorts,
and many of his works during this time burns even properly released until after
his death.
When public opinion on him had come back around another unavoidable subject
regarding Twain was his use of racial slurs and some of his work most notably
the adventures of huckleberry Finn show,
these types of words were unfortunately very common in the pre civil war era
that the novel was set in,
but it often led to schools and institutions banning the book out rights or
limiting its readings.
Multiple times.
Plane moved to Manhattan, New York city, not long after his daughter,
Susie passed away from meningitis in 1993, his beloved wife, Olivia took ill.
So Twain moved them to Italy for a time where she eventually died.
The next year. He then went into the breeze for a bit,
moving back to New York city and eventually back to the state of Connecticut in
Redding in 1996,
a close friend of his had all their home and possessions destroyed in the
infamous San Francisco earthquake train offered to autographs and portraits of
himself to raise money, to help,
and even had new portraits of himself commissions.
It begins to pen chapters of his autobiography showing this.
It was beginning to think of his own legacy and how the world should see him.
Now that he was becoming aware that his own life was nearing its end.
Also in 1906, he started a club for young girls,
perhaps Owings at the loss of his own daughter, dubs,
the angel fish and aquarium club and consisting of females,
age 10 to 16 Twain cold, the starting of his foundation,
his life's chief delight.
They exchanged letters and went to plays and other social gatherings together,
even befriended one 11 year olds named Dorothy quick on an ocean voyage,
whom he remained close to until his last days,
Dwayne didn't have the same prolific literacy output in his last years that he
did when he was younger, 1890 threes put in, had Wilson Del Smithy,
familiar idea of where two people switched positions and was hastily released to
keep him from going completely broke. Bankruptcy did rear its ugly head.
The next year.
And Twain had to resort to doing articles for periodicals and reviews and
newspapers to try and scrape together. Some funds once Olivia died,
he began to release some works from his past that hadn't met a muster when she
was alive, besides being the love of his life.
She had obviously proven to be quite the editor for his famous works.
Once that partnership was missing, the quality and tone was a lot more cynical.
His autobiography was even a difficult venture for him as he thought it would be
more entertaining to skip around time periods of his life,
which is likely why frustrated historians have to wait a hundred years after
Twain's death to release it.
But that's exactly the length of time Mark Twain wanted.
So maybe he was laughing from beyond the grave.
There were many ups and many downs.
Clara has middle daughter was married in 1909, but then his youngest daughter,
Jean died the same year from an epileptic seizure.
It was enough to nearly break the man and he swore he would never write another
word again. After the tragedy,
he instead took his bit of feelings out on the welds that he saw around him.
He believed that America was overstepping its bounds on a global scale.
And he vehemently spoke out against the war in the Philippines. And yes,
of course still put pen to paper. So to speak. He released a novella,
the man that corrupted Hadley Berger fictional piece,
dealing with the evils that humans can create when left to their own devices.
And the sins of vanity letters from earth came soon after a scathing review of
religion in which Satan condemns the way humans blindly worship one,
particularly striking passage goes,
he prays for help and favor and protection every day. And does it with hope,
furnace and confidence do, although no prayer of his has ever been answered.
Twain still had trouble adjusting to a life without the love of his family.
And so looked for brief connections whenever he could find them.
He befriended local farmers and hosted parties for the big names of the time
like Helen Keller,
who he actually bestowed the famous nickname of the miracle worker,
his humor dark as it was by this time extended even to his own approaching
passing. When rumors of his demise would swell around.
It'd be quick to jokes that the reports of my death was an exaggeration.
When talk of his last moments arose, it was contemplated a distinguished man.
It should be as particular about his last words as he is about his last breath.
You should write them out on a slip of paper and take the judgment of his
friends on them.
He should never leave such a thing to the last hour of his life and trust to an
intellectual spurt at the last moment,
to enable him to say something smart with his last dust gasp and launch
into eternity with grand jury in 1835,
Halley's comet burst through the night sky on its closest known approach.
Mark Twain was born two weeks after when the famous comment was set to make its
next past. In 1910 Twain had big plans.
He truly believed he was meant to come into the world with the comments and then
to leave it on the next go around. And he did one day after it passed us.
The two unaccountable freaks as he remarked came in and went out together,
all Twain,
put a special emphasis on the importance of one's last words he didn't fail to
deliver while on his deathbed seat.
First pointed to a stack of unfinished written works and dotted to his
biographer throwaway. He then held the hands of his last remaining daughter,
Claire. And during a short goodbye spoke if we meet famous last words.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Do not forget to subscribe also,
please do check it out. Fantastic sponsor Nord VPN linked to below,
and thank you for watching.